heures sur public sénat
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat cette semaine la
mission d'information présidée par la
sénatrice ump de paris chantal jouanno
sur les dispositifs médicaux
implantables a poursuivi à ces auditions
objectif de cette mission éviter un
nouveau scandale sanitaire comme celui
des prothèses pip est temps fort des
travaux de la mission cette semaine
l'audition de muriel à gelos et la
présidente du mouvement de défense des
femmes porteuses de prothèses et
d'implants audition que je vous propose
tout de suite de suivre bonne matinée à
tous d'abord permettez moi de remercier
madame muriel agelou qui est présidente
de du mouvement de défense des femmes
porteuses d'implants et de prothèses la
remercier parce qu'elle a fait un long
périple pour arriver jusqu'à nous dans
un ton absolument record en arrivant à
défier outre les grèves les
embouteillages permanents pour venir de
l'aéroport donc merci merci madame
comme vous le savez cette mission
d'information a fait suite au scandale
des prothèses pip et qui nous a
interrogés sur les conditions
d'encadrement des dispositifs médicaux
implantables et au delà de ce 1 de
l'ensemble des interventions à visée
esthétique que ce soit la chirurgie mais
aussi la médecine la médecine esthétique
et malheureusement c'est vrai qu'après
d'affaires dit pays payer d'autres
affaires comme les sons les sonde de
défibrillation oriettas où les prothèses
de hanche du puits depuis parle donc on
souhaite trouver les meilleures
solutions pour améliorer le dispositif
même si pour la faire pipe en plus on
était vraiment dans un cas de fraude
manifeste on ne refait pas nous la faire
entrer guillemets pipe
pour autant on souhaite améliorer le
dispositif on souhaite voir comment
au-delà des aspects de préjudice
physique il y a aussi un préjudice moral
qui est important est que beaucoup de
des intervenants nous on nous ont
signalé que ce soit dans la dimension
psychologique préalable jusqu'au
préjudice moral en k2 en cas de
difficultés alors je me dois donc de
vous informer vous l'avez peut être
constaté que cette audition est ouverte
à la presse et au public qu'elle est
enregistrée qu'elle retransmise sur le
site du sénat il faut le savoir si vous
en étiez d'accord ça c'est pas de
difficulté très bien donc notre
rapporteur bernard casion là quelques
questions à vous poser pour commencer
vous présentez afin de présenter le
mouvement que vous présidez
je pense que les conditions qu'elle a
créés sont évidents mais combien de
patience le fédérative et comment
s'organise vos contacts avec les autres
associations de victimes à la fois en
france et dans d'autres pays
alors le mouvement de défense des femmes
porteuses d'implants et de prothèses mdf
pib a vu le jour le 3 mai 2010
pour faire suite bien évidemment à la
sphère pays paie aujourd'hui nous avons
1300 membres mais c'est fluctuant parce
que tous les jours de nouvelles
personnes s'inscrivent sur notre site et
recherchent des informations et
souhaitent être accompagnés dans leurs
démarches
pour ce qui est de nos relations avec
les autres associations nous essayons de
travailler en bonne intelligence et de
collaborer sur les projets que nous
pouvons mener les unes et les autres
pour ce qui est des des associations à
l'étranger nous avons eu plus de
contacts avec des cabinets d'avocats à
l'étranger en particulier en amérique du
sud qui se tenait informé via notre site
sur l'évolution de la faire sur les
enquêtes qui était mené et les résultats
de ces enquêtes pour eux-mêmes pouvoir
diligentée leur propre expertise et
prendre en charge des victimes dans
leurs pays respectifs
êtes-vous relation mais le quai
ministration alors de manière générale
quelle appréciation portez vous sur le
comité de suivi national
quels sont les obstacles concrets
auxquels se heurtent aujourd'hui le
suivi des victimes
l'information et l'accompagnement
diviser les dictées victime ou par
est-il satisfaisant nous avons en
décembre 2010 mené une enquête auprès
des victimes
nous avons interrogé un millier de
victimes et nous avons exploité 255
réponse pour pouvoir justement discuter
avec les institutionnels sur les besoins
réels des victimes sur le terrain nous
nous sommes rendu compte que ce qu'il
importait pour les victimes c'était
d'avoir une prise en charge de leurs
opérations dans sa globalité
on a obtenu effectivement mois de
septembre
la prise en charge de l'exploitation en
tout cas pour les victimes qui sont
passés par la chirurgie esthétique une
partie de l'opération est prise en
charge de l'exploitation mais pas la
réimplantation et c'est ce qui pose
problème pour la majorité c'est que
cette partie là de l'opération est
payante et les chirurgiens en dépit de
ce qui a été demandé
concernant le tact et la mesure ne sont
pas forcément dans ce cadre là et
beaucoup de femmes même si elles
présentent des ruptures ou des fuites
avérées retardent leurs opérations du
fait du coût de la réimplantation parce
que leur souhait est d'être réimplanter
donc cette enquête a été l'ouverture
vers les institutions puisque au mois de
mars lorsque nous avons présenté les
résultats nous les avons présentés à
l'afssaps
d'une part et aux sociétés savantes
d'autre part ce qui nous a permis tout
au long de l'année 2011
en tout cas pour moi d'intervenir dans
les congrès de chirurgie pour
effectivement expliquer les vraies
attentes des victimes et aussi rappeler
que nous ne sommes pas dans un cadre
2 commercial on n'est pas là pour
demander
une augmentation mammaire on n'est pas
dans ce cadre là on est dans le cadre
d'une fraude qui nous oblige à un moment
donné à être réopéré et nous avons
demandé à ce que nous soyons quand
charge dans les meilleures conditions
possibles pour le moment c'est pas
encore c'est pas encore tout à fait ça
vous confirmez que les femmes manquent
ils ont fait pour une une raison de
chirurgie esthétique aussi réimplanter
oui à 80 pour ces gens là confiance sur
de nouveaux implants non mais elles
n'ont pas le choix on ne nous donne pas
le choix
et lorsque certains chirurgiens propose
des d'autres façons de
de travailler ou d'autres possibilités
ils sont d'abord très rare et cela
implique une reconstruction qui est tout
aussi onéreuses voire plus onéreuse
qu'une réimplantation simple donc on n'a
pas vraiment le choix
le si ces femmes sont passées par la
chirurgie esthétique c'est qu'à un
moment donné elles n'étaient pas en
accord avec leur image elles ont voulu
une réparation de leur image aujourd'hui
nous n'avons pas demandé à avoir des
implants frauduleux il faut que nous les
changerons parce que ça induit
énormément de problématiques chez les
victimes et pas seulement par rapport
aux implants elles vivent très mal la
situation elles sont très inquiètes donc
le meilleur moyen pour les sortir de ce
marasme c'est effectivement
l'explantation mais elle souhaite une
réimplantation derrière à 80 % et celles
qui ne le souhaitent pas dans les 20%
restants qui ne souhaite pas la
réimplantation c'est parce qu'elles
n'ont pas les moyens de cette
réimplantation il y a un très faible
pourcentage de femmes qui ont dû fini
par dire je me fais ex planter sans rien
réimplanter derrière ça représente sur
les 20 % 5 % et ce sont des femmes d'un
certain âge qui ont décidé que ça
suffisait pour beaucoup ce sont aussi
des femmes qui ont subi des cancers et
qui ne veulent plus passer sur la table
d'opération donc elles se font exploiter
de manière définitive et ça s'arrête là
donc c'est pas non plus un choix c'est
pas n'est pas encore dans une dans une
problématique de choix le choix de
situation
et c'est très difficile à vivre et c'est
c'est aussi ce qui est problématique
c'est que cette situation depuis
l'annnonce du retrait de ces implants en
mars 2010 a induit chez beaucoup de
femmes la prise de médicaments pour pour
dépression pour des états anxiogène
enfin on est dans une vraie
problématique qui a un coût et peut-être
aussi de dès le départ on nous avait
prise en charge de manière globale ce
coût serait amoindrie et si on avait
peut-être imposer des tarifs acceptables
on serait aussi dans une situation qui
permettrait
la réimplantation dans une dans une
bonne prise en charge les chirurgiens ne
forment pas un titre disant commercial
c'est pas le moment on pouvait l'espérer
des facilités lorsqu'il explique terry
un plan alors quand nous avons mené
l'enquêté
donc en mars 2011
il n'y avait que 30 % des chirurgiens
qui proposait une prise en charge par la
sécurité sociale
donc ça veut dire que les 70% restants
ne faisait même pas les démarches auprès
de la sécurité sociale et faisait payer
la globalité de l'opération exportations
comprises
c'est d'ailleurs oui c'est pour les
femmes pour la chirurgie oui elle était
prise en charge
c'est là sur réseau structuré pour les
recos non non pour l'esthétique
reconstructrices on a eu peu de souci
parce qu'effectivement les chirurgiens
ont fait dans le cadre de
les centres de cancérologie est que la
prise en charge a été relativement
efficiente
mais pour la chirurgie esthétique
il s'avère que donc au mois de mars
lorsque nous avons rencontré le
professeur revol qui était le secrétaire
général de la sof cpr eux et que nous
lui avons annoncé ça c'est ce qui a
déclenché le fait que j'intervienne de
durant trois congrès de chirurgie pour
justement rappelé que la règle du jeu
donc il n'y avait que 32% pour être
précise des chirurgiens qui proposait la
prise en charge par la sécurité sociale
donc de la partie est lente at war par
la sécurité sociale oui d'accord ça leur
coûtait plus cher mais ce que je voulais
dire ils se font pas bon parce que vous
êtes dans une région quand même les prix
sont disons légèrement sucré c'est
pareil partout
là on a en moyenne les réimplantation
coûte entre 1500 et 4000 euros
la réimplantation 4000 euros ils sont
gonflés
c'est pas les prix dans le sud ouest moi
je suis médecin
je sais combien coûtent les des
implantations et d'implantation mais
c'est ses 15 ans en 2000 c'est pas 4000
4010 pou simple oui mais ma 1500 m
c'est quand même pour certaines femmes
c'est quand même exorbitant dans la
mesure où de toute façon nous sommes
déjà endormi d'accord l'ouverture est
déjà fait pour l'exploitation et dans la
majorité des cas il suffit de
réimplanter de toute façon il faudra
fermer
donc ça ça reste dans le voilà ça fait
cher l'acte quand même un puisque tout
le reste est pris en charge mais il faut
savoir aussi que non seulement les
chirurgiens prennent effectivement leurs
dépassements d'honoraires mais nous
avons aussi les anesthésistes qui font
qu'ils font des dépassements
d'honoraires
à croire qu'ils nous réveille au milieu
de la de l'opération pour pouvoir nous
réimplanter
dans les deux cas d'expérimentation
réimplantation on est dans la majeure
partie des cas sur le même chirurgien
qui avait pratiqué la première
intervention sauf s'il a pris sa
retraite depuis
oui voilà on est dans celle de l'amour
grands devoirs celui qui avait implanté
oui tout simplement parce que la plupart
des chirurgiens qui ont implanté des
pays pays ont rappelé leur leurs
patientes
donc du coup ça fait partie de la suite
du jury voilà donc puisqu'ils ont
implanté des prothèses pip et leur prise
en charge devrait fin devrait être un
peu plus importante
tout à fait et c'est n'est toujours pas
le cas
je sais c'est parce que vous devez avoir
entendu et ce n'est pas ce qu'on entend
non plus au comité de suivi parce que
effectivement quand nous ramenons et
rapportant ce genre de cas en comité de
suivi le retour qui nous en effet tant
par les sociétés savantes que par
l'ordre des médecins c'est tout va bien
sur le terrain puisque nous n'avons pas
de plainte
donc c'est ce que nous avons expliqué
au dernier comité de suivi en disant oui
vous nous pourrions effectivement porter
plainte ou du moins déclarés les
dépassements d'honoraires lorsqu'il nous
semble prohibitif mais il faut quand
même savoir que ce sont les chirurgiens
qui nous au père et que si nous faisons
nous entamons cette démarche là nous
n'aurons plus de chirurgiens pour nous
prendre en charge on a déjà eu gentiment
ce genre de retour de leur part nous
expliquant qu'il valait peut-être mieux
être voilà à trop faire de vagues auquel
vous vous heurtez aux comités dessus je
suis là c'est le principal
c'est le principal aujourd'hui c'est
notre notre objectif c'est de trouver
une solution pour l'ensemble des
victimes qui sont en attente
d'opérations ou qui sont dans la
recherche d'un chirurgien qui va les
prendre en charge avec un coup à minima
parce que beaucoup n'ont pas fini de
payer déjà leur première opération
elles se sont endettés pour faire cette
opération-là initialement et elles ne
peuvent pas se sent d'été plus pour
pouvoir être exploitées et encore une
fois on n'est pas dans un choix
dictée par l'esthétique ou quoi que ce
soit on est dans une nécessité quasi
vital pour ces femmes-là s'est très
c'est très compliqué de porter ces
implants vraiment ces implants ont un
impact tant sûr d'un point de vue
physiologique d'un point de vue
psychologique ils ont un impact au
quotidien parce qu'on sait qu'ils sont
fragiles donc ça induit des changements
dans notre façon de vivre on n'attache
pas notre sécurité de notre ceinture de
sécurité de la même façon ne portent pas
nos enfants de la même façon on ne joue
pas de la même façon avec nos enfants
certaines a arrêté de faire du score de
peur d'induire une rupture
voilà donc on le haut comité de vous
aviez demandé préalablement que soit
posée principe d'interdiction
dépassements d honoraires et à la limite
que les patientes né à payer que la
prothèse vous pouvez bien sûr on l'a
demandé on la demandait dès le départ
duquel est ce principe qui fait qu'on
s'y opposer alors pour les sociétés
savantes il n'est pas possible d'imposer
une façon de faire au chirurgien
oui mais voilà je vous dise qu on nous
répond ça n'est pas possible de dire
voilà il faut agir comme ça donc a été
rappelée effectivement le principe de
tact et de mesure d'autre part on ne
peut pas non plus imposer un tarif
général est le même pour tous les
chirurgiens ce qui paraissait interdit
donc toutes les
tout ce qui pourrait effectivement
cadres et la prise en charge des
victimes ne semble pas possible aux yeux
des chirurgiens en tout cas c'est ce que
l'on nous répond depuis deux ans
maintenant
nous avons même parce qu'il ya quand
même des chirurgiens qui qui
effectivement ont pris en charge les
victimes deux pays paie d'une manière
exceptionnelle et nous avons souhaité
les mettre en avant
histoire de faciliter en fait leur accès
pour les victimes en disant ben voila si
vous êtes dans telle région tels
chirurgien est prêt à vous prendre en
charge et à ne vous faire payer que les
prothèses de remplacement ou alors
vraiment à minima ce que ce que ça
pourrait coûter nous sommes fait taper
sur les doigts en dix ans n'a pas le
droit de faire ça ça s'appelle de la
publicité les médecins n'ont pas le
droit d'avoir la publicité donc nous ne
pouvons pas faire ça nous avons même
proposé une labellisation pour que les
chirurgiens et une sorte de deux labels
sur sur leur site officiel sur le site
des sociétés savantes un label dédié qui
permettrait aux victimes lorsqu'elles
recherche un chirurgien dans leur région
de voir ceux qui adhèrent à un cahier
des charges très spécifique à la prise
en charge des victimes de pays p il n'ya
aujourd'hui qu'une dizaine de
chirurgiens qui ont voulu adhérer à ce
système là oui c'est ça on a établi un
cahier des charges avec ce que nous
attendions nous victimes
en termes de prise en charge ce que les
chirurgiens pouvait proposer de cohérent
dans cette prise en charge
ce qu'il n'y a pas qu'une question de
tarif parce que dans le dense qui est
proposé aujourd'hui vous avez des
chirurgiens qui propose effectivement
des prestations à 1600 euros
mais dans des conditions qui sont
parfois limites en termes de prise en
charge on va proposer de l'ambulatoire
sans tenir compte de l'état
rés
des prothèses ou de l'état physique des
victimes
on va même proposer jeu nous avons eu
des propositions avec
des anesthésies locales pour limiter les
coûts justement d'anésthésie donc après
on tombe dans des choses qui sont
totalement aberrante et auquel face à
ces cas là nous sommes obligés de
demander aux sociétés savantes ou à
l'ordre des médecins si oui ou non
c'est cohérent si c'est acceptable ou
pas par les victimes ou si c'est de la
boucherie que l'était le cahier des
charges que vous aviez proposé dans les
propositions alors il était il restait
encore à travailler avec les sociétés
savantes et en collaboration avec elle
sur ce qu'il voit là sur ce qu'il peut
être proposée par les chirurgiens et qui
semble cohérent dans le cadre des prises
en charges d'exploitation et de
réimplantation l'accueil général des
victimes et le suivi des victimes
est ce que une des problématiques de la
gratuité par rapport aux chirurgiens
c'est le suivi nous sommes quand même
dans un cadre bien particulier qui est
médicale avec un suivi qui est quand
même qui peut être lourd
un problème de satisfaction un problème
aussi de rejet un problème donc la
gratuité il fallait aussi qu'elle aille
jusqu'au bout de la sécurité et de la
prise en charge en cas de problématiques
postérieur
lesquels sont les oies d'indemnisation
qui seront ouvertes aux victimes
aujourd'hui oui c'est une bonne question
on en aura on aura une partie de la
réponse aux procès quand il aura lieu
sachant que vous n'allez pas de réponse
non on a les voies logique est habituel
de l'oniam
mais avant d'aborder cet aspect là de
l'indemnisation il faut déjà passer par
les voies légales et pénales une fois
qu'on aura eu épuisé je dirais les voies
pénal on passera aux civils après le
voici ville on passera donc en fait
c'est pas une temps un problème
d'indemnisation c'est aujourd'hui c'est
un problème de prise en charge plus que
d'indemnisation et il n'y a pas encore
de projection à ce niveau la batterie
mais il faudra combien de temps pour
pour passer ses lois pénales et civiles
déjà pour la voie pénale pour avoir eu
un juge d'instruction
dix-huit mois après le début de la faire
c'était déjà bien l'eau nous n'avons
toujours pas de date pour le procès
concernant la tromperie aggravée
normalement c'est en fin d'année mais
rien n'est moins sûr quant au procès
cette fois au pluriel
concernant les blessures involontaires
aucune date n'a été défini aucun
planning a été défini donc on n'en sait
pour l'instant on n'en sait rien et très
franchement c'est pas là dessus que nous
nous appuyons pour une prise en charge
la prise en charge elle doit être
aujourd'hui il y a plusieurs voies
possibles pour la prise en charge c'est
vrai que l'état pourrait effectivement
se substituer à nous pour nous prendre
en charge et se retourner contre les
responsables de cette situation
il pourrait aussi y avoir une
possibilité si si tout le monde se met
autour d'une table et en discute
peut-être de proposer des prêts à taux
zéro pour celles qui ne peuvent pas
financer
tout de suite leurs opérations avec un
cautionnement étatique qui permettrait
aux banques d'assurer ses prêts de toute
façon ils seront remboursés dès lors que
nous serons indemnisés en terme
d'indemnisation la seule volonté
aujourd'hui c'est d'être indemnisés de
ce que nous avons engagé comme frais
nous ne sommes pas aux états unis nous
n'attendons pas contrairement à ce qu'a
pu dire monsieur masse un jackpot
ce n'est pas du tout ça la seule chose
qui nous intéresse
effectivement c'est que nous soyons
reconnus en tant que victime et que les
frais que nous avons engagées ou que
nous devrons engager soit pris en charge
oui oui c'est la première étape mais
c'est en fait elle n'est engagé que pour
celles qui ont les moyens de financer la
deuxième partie voilà certaines restent
avec avec leurs prothèses abîmé parce
qu'elles ne peuvent pas envisager la
réimplantation parce qu'elles n'ont pas
les moyens
donc le stress induit par cette
situation est encore plus grand et puis
les conséquences physiologiques sont
aussi importantes
on ne parlera pas de cancer parce que
c'est vrai que la lca a bien travaillé
je dirais sur sur cet aspect là en
revanche on a des problématiques de
pathologies connexes qui sont en train
de faire d'apparaître et lorsqu'on à 20%
de personnes qui se plaignent des mêmes
pathologies de la même des même maux est
sans lien entre elles ça commence à
devenir inquiétant pardon il ya un point
que j'ai pas très bien compris
l'exploitation est prise en charge mais
vous nous avez dit que seulement 30% des
chirurgiens ont fait les démarches pour
la prise en charge
on met en mars 2011 quand nous avons
fait notre enquête on en était là
ensuite il ya eu effectivement une
amélioration parce que nous avons voilà
il ya eu la médiatisation il ya eu aussi
aussi les interventions dans les congrès
où effectivement ça fait partie des
points sur lesquels j'ai beaucoup appuyé
et du coup la prise en charge a été
mieux mieux fait
l'information auprès des vieilles des
victimes aussi a été mieux mieux fait à
ce niveau là et la facilité de la prise
en charge par la sécurité sociale est
aussi rentrer en ligne de compte
c'est tout un ensemble d'informations et
d'accompagnement qui c'est qui s'est mis
en place et qui a permis une meilleure
prise en charge pour l'exploitation mais
c'est vrai aussi que la les sociétés
savantes comme l'ordre des médecins sont
beaucoup intervenu pour expliquer que
cette partie là devait impérativement
être prises en charge par la sécurité
sociale et qu'il était hors de question
de voir encore des devis ou
l'explantation été mise mise dans le
devis
forte implantation dépassement
aujourd'hui non nous n'en avons plus on
les surveille la question c'est est-ce
que vous vous heurtez à des
exploitations avec dépassements
d'honoraires pour la partie alors à
priori non sauf pour des cliniques
totalement privée et hors convention et
celles ci on proposait dès le départ des
prises en charge de victimes avec des
tarifs entre guillemets avantageux et du
clé en main sauf que là c'est à la
charge la plus totale des victimes
alors que faudrait-il faire selon vous
pour éviter la répétition d'incidents
liés aux défauts de sécurité des
dispositifs médicaux implantables
comme pour tout ce que le cadre
réglementaire de la gauche doit être un
peu non
c'est à dire pour nous semble adapté
alors pour ce qui est de la sécurité
sanitaire c'est vrai que si on agissait
dans le milieu médical comme on agit on
agit dans l'industrie en général avec
des contrôles inopinés des prélèvements
sur toute la chaîne de production avec
expertise contrôle
et analyse des produits sur toute la
chaîne de production in situ je pense
qu'effectivement on aurait pu se rendre
compte en tout cas de des problématiques
de la sphère de la société pays paie à
l'avenir c'est vrai que si on met en
place ce genre de contrôle on ne devrait
plus avoir ce type de problématique
ce qui est peu rassurant
aujourd'hui c'est de se rendre compte
qu'un stylo à bille quelconque et plus
sécurisé que ce que j'ai dans la
poitrine parce que l'inspection la
répression des fraudes peut aller dans
n'importe quelle usine arrêter les
machines de production faire des
prélèvements les analyser et si ceux ci
ne sont pas conformes au cahier des
charges
toute la production est jeté pour ce qui
est des dispositifs implantables du type
des prothèses mammaires
non c'est pas le cas a priori ce n'est
encore pas le cas et on attend que ça
soit les fabricants qui donnent leurs
propres échantillons à ceux qui les
contrôlent il ya là des contrôles
inopinés
oui au début de contrôle sont fait
inopinée et les contrôles son entreprise
donc ce qu'il faut faire c'est des
contrôles hors entreprise sur le
matériel vendu et pour l'entreprise de
manière inopinée qu'elle n'ait pas la
possibilité si les
déviantes et de pouvoir s'adapter
oui la plupart des fabrications ne se
font pas en france donc de toutes façons
les échantillons qui seront donnés sont
des échantillons qui seront forcément
exemple de ne pas dire qu'il n'ya rien
là vous avez affaire à un escroc
donc ça rajoute au reste on ne peut pas
dire qu'il n'y a rien il ya des règles
mais règle en plus haut ce qu'elles sont
bafoués par un escroc à lui demande
tout est possible dans tous les domaines
et là encore pire puisque c'est le
domaine humain mais c'est vrai que vous
avez raison il faut que les contrôles
inopinés et qu' il soit fait il soit
fait dans des conditions leur nom on est
très très en faveur de sa de sortir de
cette mission en instituant des
contrôles qu'ils soient adaptés au
système parce qu'il n'y a pas autant il
ya un contrôle des médicaments
autant il n'y a pas de contrôle vrai
contrôle vrai il ya des certifications
n'y a pas de contrôle ouvrait des
dispositifs médicaux tout à fait blanc
de l'asmo pareil par rapport à la
au contrôle étant donné que pour ce qui
est du gel de silicone il n'y a qu'un
seul fabricant de gel de silicone
médical c'était aussi facile et ça sera
facile à l'avenir de contrôler que les
fabricants d'implants utilise bien ce
gel il suffit d'un contrôle comptable on
n'est même pas dans un assez simple à
mettre en place et ce n'est pas si
onéreux que ça mais au moins ça permet
un contrôle qui soit efficient quant à
la loi de 2002 et à l'obligation
d'information renforcée c'est vrai que
pour la plupart d'entre nous nous avons
été informés des risques que nous
prenions à passer par la chirurgie
esthétique et à passer par une chirurgie
mammaire avec implantation de prothèses
c'est vrai le fascicule que l'on nous a
remis est extrêmement long à lire
extrêmement fastidieux et je ne suis pas
sûr que en termes d'information
renforcer le fait de donner de la
lecture soit vraiment le meilleur moyen
d'informer les gens d'abord parce qu'il
n'y a aucun contrôle réel de que cette
lecture et bien été fait mais au delà de
ça c'est la compréhension de ce qui est
lui qui doit être vérifiée
et ce n'est toujours pas le cas mais ça
c'est d'une manière générale même pour
la charte du patient hospitalisé au vous
donne de quoi lire mais on ne vérifie
pas si la personne à qui on a donné ce
fascicule est capable de lire et de
comprendre ce qu'elle y met en tout cas
on vous fait signer le fait que vous
l'avez bien lu
alors dernière question que le regard
que votre enfant porte-t-il sur le
tourisme médical en matière de chirurgie
esthétique
je suis un peu connexes ont amplement
oui pouvoir même disons que position
pour toutes celles qui se sont fait
opérer en france par des chirurgiens
français avec un produit français
aujourd'hui on se pose la question de
savoir si l étranger on n'aurait pas été
plus en sécurité parce que j'ai mis six
ans pour j'ai mis six ans pour me
décider
j'ai fait le parcours que l'on m'a
conseillé de faire à savoir voir
plusieurs chirurgiens me renseigner sur
les méthodes surtout ça quand je me suis
enfin décidé la seule chose
effectivement que je n'ai pas vérifié
c'était le fabricant de prothèse parce
que dès lors que on m'a dit que c'est un
fabricant français pour moi j'étais en
toute sécurité
ce n'est pas le cas je n'ai pas été
chercher mes prothèses sur internet
made in taiwan je n'ai pas effectivement
je ne suis pas sorti des frontières pour
aller me faire opérer
pour essayer d'avoir des tarifs plus
avantageux ou autre je suis resté ici
comme trente à cinquante mille autres
femmes ont fait et pourtant nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans une situation qui est
dramatique pour certaines catastrophique
pour d'autres en tous cas très compliqué
à vivre
donc c'est vrai que le tourisme médical
n'est pas très tentant parce que on a on
a des craintes mais aujourd'hui en
termes de prise en charge et de sécurité
au niveau national on vient de voir et
on touche du doigt depuis deux ans que
ce n'est pas aussi aussi efficients et
sécurisant que ce que l'on aurait pu
attendre dans votre mouvement les femmes
qui qui ont adhéré en tout et opérer en
france
oui on est clairement fin nous avons
nous avons des membres qui sont à
l'étranger en particulier en italie en
europe c'était pas du tourisme non et
elles se sont fait opérer dans leur
propre pays
si vous voulez et aujourd'hui elle se
retrouve dans la même situation que nous
elles viennent chercher des informations
chez nous là aujourd'hui la majorité des
des victimes que nous avons
effectivement au sens de l'association
sont des femmes qui se sont fait opérer
en france en terme d'information aussi
de circulation de l'information sur
cette affaire il y a
pays paie à commercialiser ses prothèses
sous d'autres marques et il ya eu très
très peu d'informations qui ont circulé
sur sur cet aspect là parce qu'il y as
peut-être effectivement puisqu'on
parlait de tourisme médical des femmes
qui se sont fait opérer à l'étranger qui
portent des prothèses qui ne s'appelle
pas pays paie qui ne sont pas
estampillés pib et qui pourtant ensemble
et cette information là nous avons à
plusieurs reprises fait passer le
message pour que ça soit diffusé à une
plus large échelle les deux en france a
priori les chirurgiens nous disent
qu'ils n'en n'ont jamais posé
ils n'ont posé que des pib n'ont pas
posé de m rohff ils n'ont pas posé de mm
plan ça c'est ce qu'on nous a dit il
n'empêche si je veux bien les croire
c'est pas mais j'aurais aimé que
l'information circule aussi via les
sociétés savantes et leurs homologues à
l'étranger pour que pour m justement et
prévenir les les femmes à l'étranger et
a priori ce n'est pas le cas
l'information circule très très mal il
faut savoir que jusqu'à octobre cette
année
octobre novembre la chine
commercialisait toujours des prothèses
pip et et des femmes et c'est toujours
implantées avec ces prothèses là en
chine
les stocks des prothèses restant à la
société pib étant disponibles ça laisse
ça laisse une circulation possible très
difficile d'avoir une information de là
dessus je j'ai un contact avec une
journaliste chinoise qui justement
essaye d'amener un maximum
d'informations en tout cas sur les
composants de ces prothèses là pour
prévenir les autorités chinoises du
risque induit par ces prothèses mais en
terme de retour sur l'impact de ces
prothèses et leur taux de rupture et
autres on n'a pas d'informations pour
l'instant comme ça avait des contacts
avec d'autres associations dans dans
d'autres pays est ce qu'il ya des
dispositifs d'information et de prise en
charge qui vous semblent plus pertinents
que notre dont on pourrait s'inspirer ya
effectivement des pays alors je suis en
train de chercher qui a décidé de
l'exploitation et la réimplantation de
manière automatique
il ya la suisse mais c'est parce qu'ils
ont effectivement peu de victimes
voilà donc après ceci explique cela
peut-être je conçois tout à fait que
lorsqu'on parle de 30 mille victimes ça
soit effrayant en termes de coût mais je
le rappelle le suivi semestriel qui est
prévu depuis deux ans pour les porteuses
de prothèses pip est suivi semestriel
qui comporte une échographie voir une
irm plus les visites de
au médecin qui va prescrire ces examens
deux fois par an ça a un coût et quand
on fait sur une année le coût global de
cette prise en charge
c'est l'équivalent de ce que l'on paye
pour pouvoir être exploitées et
réimplantés parce qu'au delà de ça comme
je me disais beaucoup en sont venus à
suivre des traitements médicamenteux
pour pouvoir dormir pour pouvoir être
mieux psychologiquement et là aussi ça
un coup tous les 3 mois vous allez chez
votre médecin pour faire renouveler
votre traitement donc ça aussi un coût
pour la pour la société et peut-être que
me to boutabout ça coûterait beaucoup
moins cher de prendre en charge les
femmes totalement dans leur exploitation
et réimplantation comme c'est le cas
pour celles qui sont passés par là
scheer d'une chirurgie réparatrice coût
de 1500 c'est la réimplantation tout
compris oui car comme comme vous le dit
très justement comme si on vous ré
endormez une deuxième fois
c'est ça vous ouvre une deuxième fois et
on vous refaire une deuxième fois oui
vous ne pouvez avoir les noms dans cette
enveloppe là vous avez les prothèses
l'anesthésiste et le chirurgien puisque
tout le reste est pris en charge par la
sécurité sociale même l'hospitalisation
est prise en charge par la sécurité
sociale
donc il n'ya que cette partie là le
chirurgien étant celui qui effectivement
a la plus grosse part de l' enveloppe
puisque les laboratoires fabricants de
prothèses
oui on pour une majorité proposé aux
victimes fin pour les victimes de
limiter leurs coûts et
de proposer des prothèses accessible à
moindre coût d'accord les récents oui on
annonce la surveillance tous les six
mois que vous avez décrite avec
échographies remet et autres est présent
chez absolue oui tout à fait oui c'est
pour ça que je vois c'est paradoxal
c'est pour ça que je parle de coup c'est
que si on fait le calcul de cette de ce
suivi semestriels et jusqu'à ce que les
femmes soient exploités et réimplantés
ça peut durer déjà ça dure deux ans ça
fait déjà deux ans donc on n'est pas
encore au bout de ce processus là ça un
vrai coup et il est beaucoup plus
important que la prise en charge d'une
exploitation et d'une réimplantation ce
qui en plus ne ne va pas non plus créé
un vent de panique chez les victimes qui
vont se précipiter chez leur chirurgien
on peut le planifier on peut faciliter
l'accès aujourd'hui ça peut être tout à
fait programmables et les chirurgiens le
disent eux même si on avait une bonne
organisation autour de 7,2 cette affaire
on pourrait effectivement prendre en
charge les victimes dans les meilleures
conditions possibles et régler cet
aspect là du problème assez rapidement
en tout cas c'est ce que nous attendons
vous avez observé des dépressions
sérieux oui l'histoire
oui oui alors en termes de dépression
nous avons des femmes qui effectivement
sont dans des états dramatique
alors c'est toujours très compliqué
parce que pour certaines elles ont une
histoire qui qui est déjà assez lourde
et qui peuvent induire des dépressions
la sphère pib n'a fait que se surajouter
a déjà toute une problématique des
passages à l'acte y en a eu mais ça sera
là aussi très difficile de dire c'est à
cause de pib il y a un passif bien
évidemment il ya toute une histoire
avant avant la sphère pays paie la
sphère pib est un déclencheur pour
certaines mais c'est aussi quelque chose
qui vient vraiment se surajouter à leur
quotidien et à la difficulté de vivre en
général
quant aux pathologies que l'on peut
relever
il y a énormément de problèmes
articulaires qui a priori comme ça n'ont
pas forcément de lien direct avec les
avec des prothèses sauf que les produits
qui sont contenus dans les prothèses en
dehors du gel de silicone se sont tous
les adjuvants qui ont été mis on a
aujourd'hui peu d'informations
quoi donc on est on n'en est pas encore
à essayer de mettre des affaires le lien
on essaye on va on va s'y atteler de
toute façon par rapport au procès pénal
qui va se tenir normalement à la fin de
l'année il va bien falloir mettre en
avant ces éléments là et ça sera un
combat d'experts pour déterminer si oui
ou non il y as lien de causalité entre
les pauses prothèses du moins leur
contenu et les problématiques qui
apparaissent chez les
chez les victimes aujourd'hui on ne fait
que des suppositions
aujourd'hui on ne fait que constater et
on collectionne un maximum
d'informations pour voir si oui ou non
on peut
se poser des questions ou pas 20% de
femmes sur les 255 interrogé fin qui ont
répondu il ya dix huit 18 7% de femmes
qui nous ont répondu avoir des problèmes
articulaires avec le même type
d'expression et la même description de
leurs maux alors qu'elles n'ont rien à
voir
l'orage oui l'orage est totalement
différent leur situation géographique
est différent leur situation en général
est différente et donc il y a quand même
de quoi s'interroger sur l'impact que
peuvent avoir ces produits sur notre
organisme
mais on est on n'en est pas encore là
de cette affaire voilà qu'il n'ya pas de
lien de causalité parce qu'il ya eu des
études qui ont été menées il ya un
certain nombre d'années sur le gel de
silicone et que ça n'a pas d'impact les
maladies auto immunes n'existe pas avec
le gel de silicone c'est ce qui a été
dit au moratoire il ya dix ans c'est
pour ça qu'on a réintroduit le gel de
silicone
oui en général quand on nous parle de
problèmes avec des prothèses pré remplis
de gel de silicone c'est le gel de
silicone qui fait qu'ils posent problème
et c'est pour ça qu'il ya eu des études
et des moratoires là dessus aujourd'hui
ce dont on ne tient pas compte ce sont
les adjuvants qui sont dans ces
prothèses qui sont toxiques qui sont
irritants donc voilà c'est c'est là
dessus qu'ils effectivement il va
falloir à un moment donné se pencher
pour analyser vraiment l'impact de ces
produits sur l'organisme a priori
n'avait rien à faire dans des organismes
humains donc ça impacte sur des
prothèses n'auront pu les deux les deux
oui on a on a des problématiques qui
sont liées à des prothèses rompu on a
des problématiques qui sont liées à des
des prothèses perse pire hante et on a
effectivement des problématiques sur des
prothèses qui semble être
indemne mais qui au fil du temps se
délite
pour revenir à ce délai un peu de
surveillance régulière peut-être aussi
qu'il ya un délai nécessaire pour qu'une
femme accepte de arrivé tout de suite à
la solution plus radicale de
l'exploitation et de haut est ce que
vous sentez les femmes plutôt non il
souhaiterait en avoir envie de se
débarrasser entre guillemets au plus
vite de la protéine deux ans pour avoir
une prothèse nouvelle alors c'est pas
tant pour avoir une prothèse nouvelle
parce que beaucoup se posent la question
de que mettre à la place mais c'est
effectivement déjà éliminé ce qui leur
empoisonne leur après que je vous disais
le ce qui est proposé
en lieu et place des prothèses n'est pas
forcément satisfaisant et tous les
chirurgiens ne pratique pas ce type
d'opération de réparation de la poitrine
bardée par la chirurgie vraiment
réparatrices
donc tout le monde n'est pas très haut
mais pas au fait de ces techniques là il
faut trouver des chirurgiens donc il
faut trouver des chirurgiens qui vous le
propose donc c'est vrai que la solution
la plus simple aujourd'hui c'est de dire
on enlève et on remet la technique est
simple on enlève et on remet une
prothèse à l'immédiat on est sur une
technique relativement simple on me
qu'il faut mettre un bon produit non
mais c'est là qu'elle était à près du
brut
tout à fait mais la qualité des produits
que l'on va nous implanter à la suite se
pose aussi nommé se faire doucement
aujourd'hui on n'a pas de certitudes et
on n'a pas de
on n'a aucune certitude sur la qualité
des prothèses même des autres fabricants
on a peu de choix
il n'y a pas vraiment de choix très peu
très très peu et celle qui qui sont
passés par d'autres d'autres voies que
la réimplantation ont beaucoup beaucoup
de mal à vivre avec
parce que ça induit des cicatrices parce
que ça a une vie
c'est un but beaucoup de choses qui sont
très difficiles à vivre
mais si on vous fait une reconstruction
c'est beaucoup moins esthétique est
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus meurtrie
sens pour le corps donc il y à beaucoup
plus de cicatrices
j'ai eu une de nos membres qui
effectivement il passait par une
reconstruction sans prothèse quand elle
me disait avant j'avais une dizaine de
centimètres de cicatrices aujourd'hui
j'en ai 52 cm de cicatrices faut vivre
avec
donc la réparation d'une image de soi
à ce niveau là elle est très compliqué
quant à la base on est parti sur une
chirurgie esthétique pour se sentir
mieux pour x raisons et en venir à une
chirurgie réparatrice et se retrouver
quasiment multi les parce que c'est
comme ça qu'elle le prend en termes de
dépression c'est c'est très lourd mais
qu'est-ce que vous avez d'autres
questions sera porteur non écoutés il
nous reste à vous remercier mes
doublement et pour votre témoignage est
pour ce long périple
merci voilà pour cette audition de la
mission consacrée aux dispositifs
médicaux implantables pour la revoir
notre site internet publicsenat.fr très
belle journée à tous